(dramatic classical music)
- [Narrator] Sriracha is one of
the most popular hot sauces in the world,
but it's more than just a sauce.
The story of how this humble hot sauce
became so ubiquitous starts with this man
who came to America as a refugee
and built one of the most successful
hot sauce companies in the world.
(speaks in a foreign language)
- [Announcer] This Great Big
Story is brought to you by
Delta.
When we venture out into the world
we see all that we share.
(cheerful classical music)
- [Narrator] David Tran is
the owner of Huy Fong Foods,
the biggest and most well-known
sriracha brand out there.
Today he's treating his
employees to an elaborate lunch
of king crab, dumplings, and yes, sriracha
at a popular dim sum restaurant
in Arcadia, California.
But he wasn't always the
head of a big company.
David came to America 40 years ago
after fleeing his home
country of Vietnam on a boat.
(speaks in a foreign language)
David didn't invent sriracha,
variations on the sauce are
found throughout Southeast Asia.
In fact, it's named after
a town in Thailand with the same name.
The recipe is simple;
the bottle lists just eight ingredients,
but David's sauce has
a special ingredient.
(speaks in a foreign language)
Even though he doesn't have
any formal training in engineering,
David designed many of the
operations in his factory.
He even designed the iconic bottle.
(speaks in a foreign language)
People from different cultures
don't just understand David's products,
they adore them.
(speaks in a foreign language)
(harmonic notes)